hey y'all
you know there's no easy way to say this
there's no way that this isn't gonna be
embarrassing and cheesy and
make me feel like a malignant narcissist
but i have a special on netflix right
now it's my fifth stand-up special and
there's no sex robots in it besides me
it is no politics just jokes not a
secret ted talk i'm not gonna lecture
you how to vote i'm not no big
like
bomb
drop that's emotional um just jokes
straight up uh for 60 minutes straight
uh well there's also camel toes and
crotch sweat um
which i really need to take a good hard
look at for the next special we need to
do maybe the pussy botox or something
because it is a real rorschach test
down there
it is a real
it looks like a rorschach test like
halfway through the special i have so
much sweat around my it looks like one
of those you know
um
psychological tests that i think we
should bring back frankly
ah better help hit me
so i love you guys i'm gonna not post
too much about it because it makes me
feel cringy but here's the trailer for
my new special it's called jokes
give it up for my good friend and yours
[Applause]
yeah
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately why are you
complaining about this miracle in your
living room i'll turn this song off in
three minutes
daddy daddy daddy daddy i don't deserve
to see this
in this dick that is the move that's
illegal in the nfl i would like a big
beaver magazine please
i made 74 nickels for this bull shit we
put it on our face
we can plie down to the spelling bee i'm
on the moon it's like two crocodile eyes
coming out of the pond it's dark
should we just get in the van with that
guy
i feel like that was good can i have my
ring please
she doesn't get it
[Music]
i know can you believe i'm not married
um
this might be the last special i can do
at this octane
uh some ligaments took a hit the l4 took
a hard smashing i think i have lockjaw
please enjoy my special on netflix uh
right now and enjoy the show
[Music]
are we rolling pat
i know i have to say this on every
podcast i wasn't at january 6th
yeah
so
[Laughter]
american flag and a buffalo head
but
i have been told by my showrunner emily
noonan that i start the podcasts in a
way that is quote
awkward
jarring
and downright uncomfortable
is it i don't find that i have this
habit where i don't give any context to
the guests and we just start
mid-conversation but i like that because
a lot of times you'll have this preamble
where you're warming up and everyone's
doing bits and the hosts will be like
okay great so you're good great okay so
when i say your name jump in
welcome everybody obviously i will be in
louisville i will be in and you're like
sitting there looking at them
no here's the bathroom watch and then
they come from the dates and they go has
anyone been to the mall recently and
you're like you guys know what i'm
talking about and you're sitting there
and you're like do i talk you're on
camera i'm single you're in a single
you're like i am should i talk or
no and then you sometimes you go and
you're like i have been to the mall and
they're like
that's you
this next guy he's incredible you've
seen him unhappy thank you thank you
on the mindy project he's um he is also
from new york new york um and he now
resides in the hamptons new york his
name is adam palley
no just give me a second um i will be at
penguins pittsburgh
tomorrow for four weeks straight i
really i have a heart out i know that
you're fun
you're fucking with me but that was
perfect
the people are gonna love it i
as a guest on podcast it is infuriating
and because also because it's like it's
so hard to get anywhere or do anything
it's so hard
make it easy for the do that when i'm
gone you want to do that
fine we slap it on fine yeah flap it on
it is crazy to sit there and watch and
let me ask you i also to kind of defuse
the awkwardness for the next um
uh however long we're here um
i like to ask if we're friends my take
would be
i feel like we're
we know each other very well in like a
soul level yeah every time we hang out i
feel like we have a really good time
but who can no one can see anyone ever
and
but that's isn't that a good friend
though to me like to to me it's the type
of friends that i like in my life like
are the people that whose expectations
you already know become like an
intrinsic level like also we've been in
the game a long time like we we've known
each other almost probably 15 years
that's wild i mean i
i i just my thing with you is i don't
see you often but when i do it it's
always like oh thank god adam means i
feel the same way and i remember the
party for caa our agency at the time you
came up to me and you're like yeah um my
agent just came up to me and thought i
was max greenfield for about 45 minutes
oh yeah
that happens quite a bit
like the first i literally was laughing
so hard i had to like walk out i had to
like take a walk and that's because it
was true and the
the the the tough thing about like this
this
like world that we're in is that you
like to think like you do stand out
right you're like this is your whole
business is based on that one little
thing that makes you who you are yeah
that one like little thing in your eye
that's like this is who she is this is
what separates her and you feel it and
you you know it and it is so
disheartening to have that crushed day
indeed interchangeable that represent
you
[Laughter]
then by the way take your make your
money and
and then you go oh yeah i'm actually not
max greenfield and they go oh
oh adam
oh dude there's some exciting stuff
coming up
you know that isn't as good as max's
stuff because i just heard what he's
going max
because i've seen where max lives
like
because i'm staying in his guest room
he's nice enough to lend me his little
tesla
but i got to pay for the charging
[Laughter]
you're literally like i think of you as
like truly just like pound-for-pound one
of the funniest people i know oh my god
that's so nice of you i feel the same
way i feel like you're in a very good
place i feel like when we first met we
were both we were both in a bad place we
were hitting the pavement as like
auditioning actors
when it was like oh it was a job to
audition there's nine of me it's like
and that's good
it's fine but it's like you know also
anti-semitic when they're like i have
enough of that
you're like you look like
both the guys on the new girl ha ha it's
like you mean the jewish characters yeah
yeah yeah yeah which is similar like
when i get a lot of like people will be
like i know you
but i i like i don't know you
and then like the first thing out of
their mouth will be like
do you know
do you know liz feldberg
this is any joke and i'll be like any
jew and i'll be like what
and they'll be like cause you look like
my
my friend liz has a daughter named
stephanie who is married to this
wonderful man named joshua
you
you're spitting image of him
it's like
cause i'm jewish i get the same thing
except i get
are you the girl from the progressive
commercial
oh my god how do you feel about the
like you know jewish actors playing
jewish characters oh uh and it might be
a case-by-case thing but you know this
is talk i saw sarah silverman was
talking about it recently and i i i
really
love like think she has a good
handle on like being a modern day jew um
but uh and i liked what she was saying
i don't know i
recently you know had to like go through
this a little bit because i played a
character in happy endings it was a gay
character yeah and so i recently had to
like
deal with that in a lot of ways which is
okay
it's good to deal with it it was fine i
don't feel any i say i say this all the
time when i'm asked like in seriousness
about it i don't feel any
um
like shame in
doing that character because i think we
did it
what the right way can i just but i do
feel bad can i just really quick i'm
sorry i am so a
you we i mean apologizing for things
that happened 10 years ago just so it's
so fucking petty and it's people that
are just want to get you because here's
what
a straight guy who's very straight
at that time playing a gay guy was being
like yeah i'm not homophobic it's like
this it was kind of like a cool thing in
a way at the time to go like oh yeah
like you know yeah you but
now in hindsight which everything is in
hindsight but at the time you know i
mean you're also not going to apologize
for your shitty fucking haircut 20 years
ago and you're ugly yes shoes 20.
comedy is fashion and everything
everything we've done up to this point
in this podcast i don't know if we've
actually said anything cohesive but will
be offensive in 10 years it's just how
it is every all the clothes we're
wearing will be out of style and totally
i i just i feel like the one thing that
is unfortunate about the time was that
it came at this like crossroads where
where i mean now who knows what's going
on but like where
um
it could have been done another way i
think at the time had had could have
been done another totally but so so
there are people that that didn't
that maybe auditioned and didn't get it
or
maybe that we know but they might not
have been as funny as you maybe but they
may have gone on to have like huge
successes it's like i feel bad for them
at the time
that they had to like that there are
people that there are people that could
have looked at that and been like i
didn't get this part
because of whatever because you were
funnier no because because they people
weren't comfortable
at the time with an actor of a different
yeah they were
maybe i don't know you didn't get it
because your
producers were homophobic
no i know had there been the perfect gay
actor for the part they would they're
just they're just we're only now getting
to a point where a lot of the people
making shows have any kind of accent
you're not allowed to ask people if
they're gay you're not allowed to say
can i you you that's this is something
that is that that nobody will really
talk about and it's i'm saying as
someone that i feel like
we're all really working hard to get
these inclusivity writers working and
making sure everything is you know equal
and fair but you're not allowed to say
hey can i get a black grip you can't do
that so right that's why i've been
talking to these people trying to do
these like it's almost like tinder for
crew like these are really uncomfortable
conversations that everyone's so afraid
of having that nothing gets done because
no one wants to say the wrong thing but
it's illegal to ask someone's age if
they're pregnant if they have kids like
any of that stuff and it's only rece and
also let me just shift the blame a tiny
bit from creators and writers and
casting directors to agents at that time
we only had access to people that agents
were showing us so people forget like
you know agents were the gatekeepers
back then you couldn't just fight you
there was no internet you'd say hey do
you have a gay character they'd be like
no we don't you're like right we're
seeing these people they decided and
agents i'm not like
all that harvey weinstein shit how do
you think the actresses got to the
hotels
no i mean i i will say like the way that
i got the part was i read for the other
character
and
they
didn't know if
they
they were looking at max greenfield at
the time and they didn't know if they
could have two jews
this is for real play the two
like they were like we can't have joey
and chandler both be jews can you make a
show called too many jews i no i can't
i can't
not now
uh and like so
david because he's you know a genius was
like you know what
did the show david cass was like just
read for the other character but don't
do anything like read it the way you
just read
which is the opposite of problematic
it's like because you wouldn't put
something on if you were gay right so i
was like okay so i went in and did the
part now in the part there are a lot of
like
gay jokes
right so it's like you are
it's tough to it's tough it's a sitcom
it's like it's tough to know how you're
landing on that so do you move to the
world like oh god happy endings is now
having like a revival on netflix people
are enjoying it and you have to feel bad
no i mean like i i i didn't know what
was going on by the way there's a lot of
jokes about straight people yeah i'm not
sure most of them i didn't know it was
going on till i did z-waves show the
second time yeah that's the that's when
you get your report card that's when i
got my report and i didn't know like the
first time i did z-wave's show i knew
what was what was up what was it i you
know i did a movie called dirty grandpa
and uh i wore um
uh cornrows
wasn't great
i mean
was my call i was gonna say could she
please interview producers and directors
of the people but it was like but the
thing with z-way is she's to me the
funniest fucking like talent she is the
best improviser she's so fucking funny
and she's so on it and and if you know
that when you're doing it with her it's
like
i would love to do a 10 minute roast of
why i had
cornrows in a shitty movie in like a bad
robert de niro movie let's do it it
sounds fucking hilarious the second time
it's nice to release the shame a little
bit yeah okay cause it's like i don't
know i mean any
person with a brain is like yeah he
didn't know like yeah but i think that
when you're in comedy there's a little
bit of uh
you are
comedians now and and comedic actors are
held to standards
that are so
not that those shouldn't be the
standards we're held to but it's like
madonna or cornrows for like six years
like the music business is so scuzzy and
disgusting that people don't even bother
like even thinking about it drama
they're never i mean they're like you
can't make rape jokes it's like csi
hookers or hookers getting raped and we
put our finger in the cavity and we
pulled out some semen in this hooker and
this and you're just like in drama it's
okay to for women to just get raped
constantly and be like dead raped
hookers and then you make one joke and
everyone's like
it's like it's odd that that's
normalized and we're being put under a
microscope i think it's like it's
twofold on that level too because it's
like i think the context of it is the
reason that madonna didn't go on
z-wave's show to talk about her cornrows
right is because she's not
a comedian
do you know what i mean so it's like
it's like you get a funny i i understand
and so it's like i i went on knowing
that that was gonna be like boom the
image yeah like giant on showtime and
being like well this is gonna be funny
because it's z-way and she's funny
people that are fans of comedy
understand they're like this was funny
10 years ago oh not great i mean over
the pandemic i rewatched
charlie and the chocolate factory oh boy
dude it's wild
like if if you guys want to start having
probably dying dude killing kids die
like horrible deaths and this gene
wilder one of my heroes but he's just
like hey children come in killing them
it's easily 77 what about the fact that
oompa loompas are is that's like slavery
okay
he boated them in from another place i
just think there's a point where it's
like do you want to enjoy there's so
little to enjoy right now do you want to
just like drop the charges and enjoy it
for what it is if you need to see what
date was that came out if you need to
like i'm not going to watch charlie
chocolate be like these special effects
suck because they do it's like
construction paper it looks like shit
but i'm like i know when this was made
but i also think and this is one of the
geniuses of z-wave's show and i think
it's why like what i love about her and
similar to you is like if you're funny
if you're funny for real and you like
funny in your bones
then those mistakes that you made
you you want they're part of you they're
part of the thing yeah do you know what
i'm that's part of your it's like going
that
to not know them or acknowledge them or
have thought about it in a comedic way
is to not be is to be what you're saying
to be like oh god you know what i mean
real quick yeah is this whole cancer
culture thing with comedians a sneaky
way to get people to watch things that
we've been in 10 years ago possibly i
mean i i did something really offensive
i mean louis won a grammy dirty grandpa
i mean please don't watch it no first of
all i don't get residuals from dirty
grandpa that's what i wanted to say one
of the things i did say to her was like
i just want you to know i was number
like 37 on that call sheet
so if you think i was like making
creative choices
like hey i think the cousin nick
character would be great in cornrows
like you think i did that the best part
of cornrows is it's not just like a
a casual it takes like eight it's like
an hour out of a salon and even in the
salon the people doing my hair were like
this is a bad idea
bad idea
you know i was like i think it's funny
i came back they said you're like a
barber shop yeah they died i remember i
was in atlanta i remember i came back
from atlanta i came back from like
midtown atlanta east atlanta
and the fact that you did it in atlanta
i feel like extra point of course i came
back from the barber shop in east
atlanta with like these
really tight cornrows so tight that my
eyebrows were like pulled back oh i got
them now i had a du-rag on and i
met
jason manzook is in the lobby for dinner
and he turned around and went upstairs
he said he wouldn't have dinner with me
i was like
i'll wear the do-rag he's like that's
adding to it
i have to keep it tight for shooting
tomorrow he's like
you should have said no he i remember
like you should have said no
i was like i thought it was funny he's
like it's not funny
and it was just it is odd when i think
you know i think
something i'm working on is catching up
to where i am and we'll never know where
we are and i think we have such career
dysmorphia
and i think that we for so long it was
like
yes i'll wear the padded bra yes i'll
wear the wig yes i'll lose 100 pounds
yes i'll say this thing that i don't
think
is funny or that isn't and it was just
like
it was for so long it was like
paycheck to paycheck like i don't know
when i'm gonna work again and i have to
do this well i mean i did last comic
driving not even standing
i was in a car i hosted a game show
a year and a half ago that didn't get
picked up
about bob ross
by the way
that sounds i i that would that show
would be massive yeah it didn't get paid
it would be massive that's how bad you
know it was who is it but here's the
thing now a lot of times when things
don't get picked up now for the tv dorks
out there sometimes it just means the
network completely went away it's not
you know that's true it's about to
happen now i don't know they're like
this will be on true tv it's like
where's the stream 100 places to party
before you die this is like
truly a dream it's funny i'm not even
joking like this is uh i just did this
show uh uh just one episode of kesha's
got a show where she's just going to
haunted places and chasing ghosts and it
was just like it's great this is what i
want to watch don't tell me how to vote
don't lecture me and tell me i'm an
asshole like people that just like work
they just want to laugh this looks so
that's what we did i mean we were
basically like our favorite show my
favorite show i won't speak for for john
but uh my favorite show is the trip with
steve coogan oh yeah yeah
because it's just like nothing it's just
like it's in the sweetest of ways it's
nothing like even the later ones i like
better than the first one when they like
had a story i like even like the ones
where they truly are doing nothing
because here's what i'll say now the way
that we consume meat i think we're all
very primed for things to be fragmented
and they don't have to be linear and
they don't have to be i need to be able
to dip in and out whenever i want and i
wanted to play while i'm making dinner i
wanted to play while i'm hungover during
january 1st like it's like that's and i
like that kind of programming and so
when we when we came up with it we were
like i think it would be really funny if
instead of like
you know learning anything or or like
going to these places and finding out
like how horrible america is because
they colonized everything maybe we just
like get fucked up there what if we just
and like celebrate what is working yeah
it's like what if we just went to a
really nice restaurant that is run by
some cool people and then we went to
like a funny museum wasted and that was
a joke and then we kind of like rented a
boat
and like
and that's it you mean everyone's dream
day yeah what if i just did what
everyone else enjoys doing yeah and we
didn't and it's like the f and i love
the thing i'm really proud of is that
it's it's high low it's not like
what are some places that you went 101
places i mean i have really good recs
now which is new for me because i feel
like usually i'm texting you but i feel
like i
like richmond virginia
richmond
college in richmond is a is a town that
i
feel a deep connection to now where when
i first got there i was like i don't
think i'm welcome here because it's like
super colonial when you especially when
you dip in you like drive in and you
drive by like
crazy courthouses and did you feel this
because you're jewish yes oh wow well
there's anti one of the things you'll
see on this show is that there is rampy
rampant anti-semitism everywhere
everything and i want to talk about this
because it's it
i'm just going to say it as best as i
can and you know my my heart at this
point if you don't whatever um i feel
like it's not talked about as much
because there's it's there's so much to
do yeah that that is sort of like well
you're white enough so we'll just put i
i agree with that statement too because
it's also like how do you say like
it's like not necessarily getting shot
in the street every day but synagogues
are now just fully
i mean i mean the highland park shooting
is an anti-semitic thing like he tried
to go to a synagogue
yeah it's like if you that it's weird
that we're not like calling it that but
that's okay it's also like i also
understand it's very weird that we're
not calling it that and here's what i'll
say i i i
like knew enough cause i think
you know i'm just gonna say this the way
that i
the holocaust gets so much press yeah we
have good pr they
are like oh well that's that was the you
know now i'm cleaning up the aftermath
but i watched this documentary it's not
like
amazingly made but it's what for what
it's actually kind of magical in the way
that it's just very simple about the cat
skills and i did not know this catskills
was originated from basically because
jewish people weren't allowed in country
clubs yeah that's when my parents
got there so my parents were in a rock
band when i was a kid called pallium pal
that would tour the catskills and that's
like what that's how i grew up it was
like going to those big resorts and
playing you feel like and then it was
like dirty dancing
hitting a nerve yeah and this is
something that is obviously like
whatever someone wants to do with their
face is none of my business i am people
think i've already done crazy shit if
you think i've done crazy you ain't seen
nothing wait dude you just wait okay
this is good facials and good makeup
when this shit starts falling i the cock
and the grout it's gonna get fucking
wild oh man i'm gonna look like fucking
alec baldwin now
i'm gonna i'm gonna be like i'm gonna
look like uh the dp okay i'm gonna make
someone
i'm gonna be like someone get me the
laser gun laser gun laser
let me see it first though
but please point it at my face let me
see it first point it right in my face
this time give it to the tp let them
point it at me wildly
shoot it everywhere willy nilly
every crevice of this old irish jaunt
straight white man right now yeah
we're black
tomorrow i will be interviewing woody
allen woody allen did that happen yes
i didn't watch it but i was i wish i did
okay well we'll we'll we'll put a pin in
that cause i i could talk about that
forever by atd i did not take my prozac
today but um
as soon as the court lifts my
jurisdiction in new mexico i will be
traveling to poland to interview roland
polanski it's roman balansky and me as
soon as i sire 47 more children in a
four bedroom i ever tell you my alcohol
i don't care about that i mean this is
great my outball was you're looking at
someone i don't know who's in there i
was like is it are we good he works here
now that's what he's come to when i did
that match game i never got asked back i
did it once
and i think the reason i didn't get
asked back was because i found him to be
insane
and he like he took a liking to me early
on because i was the youngest person on
the panel
it was like a a
older panel you know friends of mine was
like mario cantona cheryl hines cheryl
hines
the crew you know the the pros the cir
the circus yeah yeah and i was like the
youngest person so he like took a liking
to me so in between jokes he would like
come down he would be like hollywood's
kind of bullshit huh like talk to me or
whatever and i'd be like yeah you know
it's weird and he's like yeah yeah tina
says that too you know tina right again
and so then like uh
he does that like
thing there's that moment where he does
like the thing where he's like comes
down on camera and he's like reading a
card about you and he's like so adam
grew up in new york city and has three
children oh three children that's really
nice they're halfway there to me my
friend and then and then they like
and then it's like hahaha they cut off
and
commercial cuts and he's standing like
leaning on my podium and i'm like hey
congratulations
again you know i saw you had another
baby that's that's that's exciting and
he goes yeah
i'm not fucking her
i wonder where they're coming from
and i was like i just
met you like
we are not
like i don't
and i was like looking around like mario
canton was like i
that's fucking crazy like i didn't
that's when i get worried it was like
someone's gonna be like like on mike
that i'm billy bush
mario kanto'd that is what it that is
called a pro didn't hear it yep didn't
you look at that
and i was like because i was so nervous
i was like oh my god i'm fucked i'm
fucked i'm like now i'm now i'm laughing
at that on camera in my mic because i
was like
you know
and it was so like and he looks at me
that's not a you don't you don't get
paid a little for that gig no you get
paid good money for that gig no he was
making hampton's money you know and so
like i was like he wasn't making lawsuit
in vermont money no
no no no wasn't making enough i don't
know
rust lawsuit in fact i've been on the
phone with tina we're gonna do 60 rock
it's right next door
we're gonna do rock bottom rock bottom
it's me and jack
have you ever read alec baldwin's book
um no but i um i have read steve
martin's book and he has a chapter about
hosting the oscars with alec baldwin
it's like super revealing hmm i
was gonna do a show with al baldwin's
ages ago and i i'm just i'm fascinated i
don't think there's anything we could
say about him that he wouldn't know or
care or give a shit i mean we had i had
a big deal with him during the president
show
yes he was so mad at me
like publicly his book is i mean it's a
reminder again that actors like are very
sensitive people which i want to sort of
loop back to like not to excuse any
crazy behavior or anything but i
remember reading being like okay i'm
doing this job with alcohol and i was
playing his daughter in a show or
something cool and um
and um
i mean i think he's a great actor i like
he's the greatest i mean like his when
he's in a nancy myers movie sign me up
okay i mean i tell you one story they
have his body in that nancy meyers movie
as my mood board if i could look like
that now
i have like bells
yeah
should we do should we do a remake we
should do like a play in that movie
where i'm playing valentine's moment for
no reason
and it's called for no reason
what
meyer's movie would be called
i love them nancy meyer i i sometimes i
keep them on pause in the kitchen scenes
that's why i th that's why i got sort of
beguiled and intoxicated by the hamptons
because i was like oh i just feel like
i'm in a nancy meyers movie that's why
it is that's what i'm doing you got a
good you got a good weekend and like a
good airbnb you can really be like i may
stay here i may actually marry this
i will find a way to um i mean you're
you're do you i found a tick on my pussy
adam yeah that's a tough that's a point
against the hampton that is a for sure
do you can i am i allowed to ask what
happened
a tick
what were you doing no not not that like
what what was that what was this fucking
a sprinkler there you go well so then
answer questions
obviously i guess it was the way
i was i was sneaking into millionaires
houses and riding their doors what was
was it just like we're playing around in
the backyard like leonardo dicaprio
style with a water gun you respect that
picture what movie is that
that like he's at one of his
girlfriend's play dates yeah he's yes
he's like a three-year-old birthday
party with a bouncy house and water gun
and he's like his shirt off and his
belly's out and he's like unbothered and
happy just like
what if he was just doing like a like um
like a rendition of his gilbert grape
character
for a fan first of all he looks like me
now in that picture and i think it's for
the revenant which is not a good sign my
favorite story about leonard dicaprio in
the revenant is like i i i'm not i don't
care there's just not enough like i get
offered parts that are so like deeply
insulting that even if it's like so
such an impressive job i'm just like i
ca i can't do that you were offered the
bear
you didn't make you read
sunlight can spoil your wine and your
good times if it's not properly stored
now is the time to get those bottles out
of boxes and off your countertops and
into a wine fridge from wine enthusiasts
this is the most sexy piece of furniture
it's gorgeous
it's stunning it's stunning wine
enthusiasts designs and offers okay
sorry
emily's drunk right now only because we
were doing the wine enthusiast ad this
is someone that i'm a method ad reader
okay
wine enthusiast why can't you be cool
mine enthusiast offers the largest
selection of wine coolers for every
drinker every budget in every size
collection from six to six hundred
bottles
plus expert wine storage consultants are
available by phone to help you find the
right fit for all your needs wine
enthusiasts is the premier destination
for the wine lifestyle offering an
inclusive and incredible selection of
unique wine accessories glassware
furniture wine storage gifts and more
the wine lifestyles sign me up finally
someone named my lifestyle w-h-i-n-e
visit wine enthusiast dot com or text
the code gfy to 511 511 not 911. that's
what you call when you need somebody to
bring you weinstat remember to text g
for f g remember to text gfy to 511 511
today to check out all of wine
enthusiasts summer savings text gfy to
511 511 today certain exclusions may
apply you may receive up to one
additional text text fees may apply text
stop to opt out when i'm not drinking
wine out of my
wine fridge
i'm drinking you don't have one i have
one you don't know what they sent me she
lives in your garage
squatters rights
i had a seeking suspicion
i'm not drinking wine i'm drinking mud
water the coffee alternative with four
remember thank god you have a boyfriend
now yeah he lives in your garage too you
haven't seen him around he is our
boyfriend
red flag when i'm not drinking wine i'm
drinking a coffee substitute
no water
ever and
mud water
it's a coffee alternative with four
adaptogenic mushrooms and
ayurvedic herbs
with one-seventh the amount of caffeine
as a cup of coffee so you get the energy
without the anxiety jitters or crap
coffee like it's uh what's it called a
gateway drug to sugar for me and dairy
and trash and whatever yeah i can't
coffee is just no bueno for this kid but
i've always been looking for a
substitute that isn't like um a uh like
a like a bouquet of daffodils so mud
water this is a cacao masala chai which
is black tea ginger cardamon cloves
nutmeg black pepper uh chaga reishi
cinnamon turmeric himalayan salt or
himalayan himalayan himalayan okay well
i know some shit you guys don't um so
nothing in here is only 20 calories you
put one teaspoon
in water and that's it yeah little honey
if you want it your favorite milk your
soy milk your oat milk i don't know you
can put some of your mct oil in it if
you're a high performer yeah right if
you're one of those if you have
cauliflower ear and you need to put like
butter in your coffee knock yourself out
you can just do it in your mud water
instead and by the way aside from how
good it is for you and how much it works
dude who's the coolest person at work oh
yeah the person with this on their desk
yeah absolutely if i saw the set of guys
i'd be like what's up what's good
organic gluten-free vegan non-gmo
whole30 and kosher yeah go to
mudwater.com whitney to support the show
and use code whitney for 15 off i just
read a review about hacks season two
that was like it's great but it's kind
of more of the same and i was like
that's what people want do you mean
season
two
it was weird it wasn't a different show
i went in and it was the same actors and
they were kind of doing the same thing
it was weird it was like
boring uh we've seen you be called by
this name
like and you're like this is a critic
writing this more of the same like
you
how deep you want them to go
[Laughter]
you want it's like what would be if i
was writing it next year they should do
hacks in space
[Laughter]
fuck are we talking about this
isn't tv you know ruining for everyone
fucking disease second season he's like
in italy yeah well mastermind two is
like i don't even know what who is the
master
none there's no you know why because no
one watches it
it's okay aziz you don't have to cut
that that's fine
well i just love when i'm like we're
just trying to get shows out there and
i'm like aziz gets to live in italy for
two years
so okay i have some things written down
because i think people do get frustrated
when i blue ball them with um not
finishing stories so really quick about
leonardo dicaprio because i feel like
you have a million stories like this
uh the revenant i i really did not enjoy
watching it i know it's a brilliant
movie i like had to leave the theater a
couple times i just couldn't deal so i
had to leave when anything was horrific
and then i just got obsessed with
researching the movie and leonardo
dicaprio so uh uh he they shot with real
light no artificial light right and he
was outside every day for like 11 months
where they shoot it like up northern
chile like like no like chile chile like
nanook of the north type shit right and
he made a character choice to wear
fingerless gloves that was like his big
like character choice in like two months
and he was like fuck
why did i do this and for like eight
more months he had to wear fingerless
gloves i've done that on sets with like
pizza
where they're like well they'll be like
a group scene and i'm eating pizza and
i'll like be like this is funny if i do
it like this and then they're like okay
so we just need to do adam single of the
pizza and then the adam's reaction to
casey with a pizza
you're like
what i was using the line right like
we're scrapping the line now it's merely
about the pizza
like i'm i have diabetes can we maybe
casey one time legit had like passed out
on on happy endings from a gag where she
had to drink mimosas
and they just and like they didn't water
down the orange juice it was like early
in the morning and she was like
and the joke was like take a chug of the
thing and people are like haha the
character can't be at lunch without
drinking numb her feelings right but
because it's like that job and
everything it was like all day and in
the middle of the day she was like i
have to go in the bathroom
and like no one saw her
and they came back they're like we're
gonna do like everyone's waiting around
on their phones like we're gonna do
casey's coverage tomorrow
[Laughter]
i love good business good business i
love business i love business as an
actor someone's like someone's like we
need to be doing something i'm like i
got just a thing
what's the line got it pull out your
thighs yeah i don't know if uh wait i
don't know what anyway
you're ready to be a single guy dan
i just think i don't know call me crazy
but like
you're 35.
you're rich
you mix race
you got everything going for it and i'm
gay and who am i i'm your gay best
friend i gotta get out of here i have a
hair appointment in atlanta oh these are
not mine
i just stole those
good business is my
this would be my actor nickname
great i'm great i'm the best with the
remote control i'm the best with the
remote control i see on tv all the time
other actors sit down they sit down for
a tv scene it's like yeah i don't know
she said she was going to
the mall and uh then we went to
we went to the mall but we didn't get
what we wanted it's like for me
we're watching tv
fucking i got it i sit down right away
i'm like yeah i don't know what was uh
going on we had
um batteries are weird
we didn't see it by the way the props
guy gets fired like shit i'm like no no
it's business
like fuck you come on calm down for greg
pops it's business
well that's what i was
when i was doing the drama the character
had kind of like a drinking problem or
like would be drinking a lot and i would
like in the scenes like plan out whereas
and then they'd be like we're gonna go
again and i'd have to be like um we
continuity on the wine like it was just
so it was like how did the actor make a
shit because i was like oh can you cause
then i'm all continuity when i i do it
all it's embarrassing to have to
advocate for your business between
taking oh i know it's so embarrassing
asking for anything as an actor is
embarrassing like because you're like i
know everybody's um
working in a physical manner that uh
really pushes you to the limit of all of
your
um strength and
it'll be dangerous to commute
home after this
um but uh
the last couple takes i've been
screaming
um
any throat coat like
and if we don't have it that's fine i'll
do it again but uh look i have wrinkle
laws in my rider they weren't in the
challenge that's true and i want to make
a problem cause this is an indie it's
small and i want to make a thing about
it you know but i do need those drops
and i will not work till i get
oh them because it just it's like
it's it's interesting because i feel
like like when we first started talking
i do oh and i want to talk about your
show because i have a theater oh i'm
doing your poster like me yeah yeah
something here's what i'm saying in
terms of people being offended by shows
that were made 10 years ago or two days
ago
i think it's important hopefully i think
this conversation is an insight into
kind of like the way
comedy writers and actors
work and how sensitive we are and how
hard we try no one is writing a romantic
comedy like i hope in 10 years this
offends people anyone that's writing a
romantic comedy good bad whatever a a
comedy tv show they're like how do i
make all these strangers laugh how do i
make my dad love me like it's the most
sensitive insecure people that are
trying to do anything for love that hey
if you hate us no one hates us more than
us it's hilarious about something i
hated that thing you did i'm like guess
what i hated it oh yeah it sucks you
should have seen what it was before i
got my hands on post i was like i agree
with you i did it for money i was a kid
i i
put myself a side of it you're the
weirder than watching it you've seen it
yeah like when people like that move you
did suck i'm like you watch that you're
like what's going on with you so many
clunkers like i just feel like you know
we are at this place where we can't
really separate intention and impact and
there are certain places where you
shouldn't you just go there's i don't
care about your intention it's imp you
should know better by now right but i
think that there's like
it's important just to remember like
it's wild to me that when that every
time you know i meet someone news
community like comedian's like
they're in a lot of pain right and then
actually on twitter people like fuck you
for that role you played 10 years ago
it's like you know
on some level people are like the
stereotype about comedians is they're in
a lot of pain they've had a lot of
trauma yet we're going to be the hardest
on them
for just trying to make someone laugh 10
years ago yeah well i think that that
that that that is also a fun
a fun thing now as well it's like
hunting in a way where it's like
people not the joe brogan podcast people
are no not that kind of not having this
guy
no but like people people are like
for every person they like every
buddy you like when you see a headline
come out about them
there's a little bit of like joy that it
might be negative you know there's like
a tinge of it so i think people hunt it
in a certain way so it's like a story
can be can grow and grow and grow
because there is a little bit of us all
of us
that get the same dopamine hit when
something bad happens or someone does
something wrong
yeah and that sean fury is like gro
grows well because it's actually it's
our brain's primordial maybe this is the
job organ podcast um it's our brains
like primordial way of watching a mass
shaming and learning from it right and
number one hiding and going him him
which protects you right then i'm not
anyone it's you're pointing a finger at
someone else you're pointing through it
yourself right yeah so it's like i'm now
distracting from the fact that of course
i've said some crazy shit i'm not
supposed to say but let's just focus on
that person and it's studying it's like
why we stopped to look at it um car
accidents rx it's definitely it's your
brain preparing for don't do that right
and and i think that that that is like
really growing the more the more that it
becomes possible to be in trouble for
things like that yeah you know what i
mean like for twitter jokes to cost you
the academy awards or stuff it's like
that
that
is so people like that story so much
yeah and they like that like that feels
like change to some people they're like
you know what was good when we shamed
kevin hart out of hosting the oscars
because of his old jokes
we we did it we fought the system and we
won and i actually don't think that's a
win i think that's more of like uh
like
you you did the same thing in a way you
would like watch seat fillers read off a
prompter that year yeah we did and it's
like you you nailed it you didn't win
you lost a talented host who didn't even
have the chance
to like deal with something that
you know is like in the ether and it's
also the one thing i will say about that
is i guess part of the reason i mean
obviously that was like just
you know what when i see stuff like that
i'm like i know kevin's gonna be okay
yeah like most people don't get most
people go we've all
also like
you know
we've all said shit thought shit like
that or whatever back in the day you
know it's sort of you're like oh i
laughed at that ten years ago so you
know what i'm a dickhead too let's just
cut our losses let's not let's do a
living amends let's not do that again
nest but i'm also big on like jokes or
jokes like that is a joke don't you
think that kevin now like don't you
think like like the thing that like i
was saying like to get him to like he
did the right thing because it was what
he wanted to do and i also think it
would have it usually hurts great
comedic actor and famous people's career
to do the oscars i remember seeing that
going oh kevin why
but i think to me the reason it came to
my mind is because it was such it was
like one of the prime examples of like
the
the
they got they
he stepped down he was like i'm not
gonna do it because it's not worth it
and like
um i agree
with
let's change his mind let's change his
jokes those jokes weren't great whatever
but like this is one of the funniest
people in the history of the world
who who's done who's done a library yeah
who is who has podcasts who has movies
who has
all who has who has been making jokes
his entire life some good mostly at his
own expense
that's what makes kevin so amazing so
like
when when that happened and then it
became this headline of like we did
enact change
that to me is different than getting
like a bill passed
do you know what i mean
the progress that gives us this little
at least i mean it's an addiction it's
it's i think i think we will look back
in 20 years you know and go remember
when people were just allowed to be on
twitter and post whenever they wanted
whatever they wanted it's a
self-righteous indignation addiction i
mean 22 percent of people make 80 of the
tweets like these are people that just
like need that the same way you and i
want to go make jokes and make people
laugh at the time they want to make
people feel bad it makes them feel
better and like you know i didn't hear
someone go what if someone watches uh
kevin hart and his movie loves him
watches him on the oscars and then this
eight-year-old kid whatever goes on
youtube googles kevin hart and sees that
joke whatever and then you're like oh i
guess i see your logic of like
me but i'm like what
like like i have an arrest in mind then
even like not to bring it not to be an
i felt my brain going narcissistic they
were like to take the conversation back
to me like i have an arrest in my record
humble brah yeah what happened drugs
like you know but when was this like
a couple months recently
no like i think like sec a long time ago
but i was
a person of known
of name
and like
does that mean that because of that i
can't be in a disney movie
or can't make a movie for kids right uh
no it doesn't it's it's but that is not
what people are coming after and they're
not coming after your personal life
they'll go oh man he must have been in a
rough spot whereas if you make a joke on
stage that everyone laughs at that's
when people go oh this person's
dangerous because something they're
saying that's offensive could ignite
they're normalizing like i believe this
is the argument of the people that
what's worse the person who's done it
and like no
again like what's worse is what i'm
saying like to me
he it's like minority report in a way
it's like i have a police record well
not anymore but i did have a police
record yeah
i wasn't hosting the oscars but like
i i didn't have at the time a joke that
was
deemed inappropriate and like i don't
know why i would even put myself in that
in a position but i'm just saying like
it doesn't feel the
the perfect record that you need to have
in order to like get through this
environment to me is sometimes uh like
um
i think that's why like
kevin was like i'm not even gonna fuck
with it here because it won't be funny
now it's not funny yeah you know well
yeah now he had to go and apologize and
he's too rich for that i mean that's the
other thing is that you guys like i mean
i think people are seeing now it's like
a lot a lot of what you're doing when
you're trying to cancel someone to go
it's like you're actually making them a
martyr yeah i argue he's more respected
now than he was before just in a matter
of like damn that was good i kind of
thought you were just like the most
talented person in the world and now
like you're a gangster now you handled
yourself the fact that you walked away
from that as someone that kind of is
like does everything and is probably
going to win 20 egots and stuff like i
don't need this like and the fact that
he didn't really back down and you know
and i and and to me look i i can't you
know i think we're in a place now where
it's like okay there's certain things
that are not okay just because people
won't laugh like i think if he told that
joke today people go
but back then they didn't you know and i
think that there's a lot of shit we're
saying today that's not gonna age well
but you know i think that there's we're
losing some teaching moments we're
losing some moments to be able to say to
your kids like yeah what this
this was 20 years ago people used to
talk like this yeah it's not okay
anymore but this is what we're up this
is this was 20 years you know it's like
the same way i mean
and and for just like
joking about this isn't funny here's why
like we're losing a lot of that and then
the kids just going to go out in the
world and they're just gonna deal with
it at school and have no exposure
because they've been so coddled because
no entertainment has shown anything
offensive yeah well that is definitely
true too and like having a kid i have a
10 year old kid who is like it's really
hard to like
he cancels me at home every day
you know for like you know what he would
term a microaggression or whatever like
and he's tan you know it's like he may
be right and i try to learn from it yeah
like when he says it to me and sometimes
i am like
shut the fuck up but also he's 10 and
he's and it's also i mean
there i i do believe this is and i you
know work with animals where when you're
training animals or rehabilitating
animals untraining them kind of they
want you to be in charge yeah they want
you and they're testing you oh i guess
we should go over here like you want to
go over here and then i'm like well you
just walk me into a fucking ditch oh
you're trying to get me to step up and
be the lead mayor and be the alpha
whatever word you want to use and you're
testing me and i can either let you walk
all over me but like guess what this
shit in the real world is gonna get you
punched in the face yeah you know and
guess what even if you don't agree with
me
i pay the bills when you're 18 you can
say whatever the fuck you want you can
talk to people however you want and
you'll learn the hard way but like i i
just this thing where
you know i'm the and i do i think i over
correct uh pat scott covet and um
join the club
i got the whole collection because i
always want to go you know i always ask
like you know grace who
um uh is uh you know my sister always
like is this okay should i not say that
and it's like and i want to check in and
get it right and corroborate but the
same way like when i ask like a native
american person everyone's gonna have a
different answer but i'm like we can't
say anything we say do we say indigenous
or native and they're like we don't care
fucking help us we live in disaster well
that's that is getting lost too and i
but i also think like um
like because there's the other side of
this conversation as well which is the
the old man of it all sure or the older
the oldness of it all cause like i do
feel like in a certain way this
conversation has been co-opted in a way
by
the
old men
against trans
rights like so funny
like
th this conversation is smaller than
that to me like this is about like uh
comedic but like
the relentlessness of these old
men comics who go after the trans
community
is so dangerous and bad to me
that
that it's gone from not it's gone from
the joke part of it to the hill they're
dying on to say what we're saying about
material do you know what i mean imagine
though this is this is v to to i think
that you know there's certain things
that i don't mean to get all like men
and women are different no of course you
know
um women be shopping i'm not i'm not
gonna pretend you know it's just it's
literally i was getting in an uber this
morning from baltimore and i had this
heavy bag you know that whatever the
bunch of net and i i literally could not
care i work i work out very hard yeah
i'm on some things that are probably
like not fda approved to be strong and
and this fucking uber guy who's like 30
pounds he's like this guy from india
he's like 98 he's picked it up and put
in the car and i'm like men and women
are different i'm sorry
but that's that's just a
that's a different just but that joke is
like is like uh
it has nothing to do with a challenged
like the
to me the bother of it and like without
like naming names of it but there's a
run of older comedians here's what it is
we okay so i just have to break it down
because if you're a woman you see the
world slightly differently do you know
what i'm saying so men have not had to
be afraid of everything so what are men
afraid of and all anger comes from fear
robots and trans women because they're
the only two people that are like have
uh they don't understand and are more
powerful than them but i think that's
perfect sense to me i i agree with you i
agree with what you're saying and i feel
like the bummer is the bummer and it's
every man's biggest fear to be with a
hooker and it at every guy every man
just like older men i guess is my thing
like it seems to be every guy every
comic had a joke 20 years ago that was
like i went to tijuana and i fucked a
hooker or whatever we called them back
then and then it was akishi right every
guy every like comic has got a blow job
from a trans but that's just gay panic i
mean that's just like and now they have
to cover their tracks but that's just
gay panic which to me was like never
funny it like it didn't make sense to me
and i feel like now
this panic because i watch some of these
guys do their material on trans and i'm
like you don't even really
believe what you're saying you just
don't like that people are saying hey i
don't like this material or like people
are saying you know what maybe you're
wrong and you don't see it because
you're older or you're not or you're gay
panic is so insane that you can't see
the humanity in this thing and and
instead of like
i don't think they shouldn't joke about
i don't care but like instead of like
going in
they go no this is the hill i'm gonna
die on and there was one comic i forget
his name is like this young british
no no young burster who was doing this
bit that like went viral who was like
making fun of ricky gervais being like
you don't like my truth i'm gonna
challenge you because you bought a
ticket so i'm gonna tell you how it is
i'm gonna tell you the truth and it's
challenging i'm ready to challenge you
ready to be challenged i'm gonna
challenge you it's like yeah cause no
one's had more of a challenge than the
trans community yeah right right like so
there is a sense of like challenge me
with something besides this this does
not you it is such a humanity it's such
a human rights thing that is now
becoming really really important that
i'm tired of having to like co-opt as a
comedian
my conversation yeah about what i can
and can't say with your
really my newt old-school gay panic i
don't understand what that means like
co-opting means like when you take like
for me like like i feel co-opted on this
conversation because as a comedian who
like has to think of bits and write bits
all the time what do you mean you feel
co-opted like i'm taking it yeah like
they're taking it like the conversation
about comedy really shouldn't be about
trans rights
that's its own thing yes
and it's very important
unfortunately because of this old-school
view of men being so afraid of
dying or getting fucked
that
that has become the comedy conversation
and it's not fair to the trans
conversation and it's also like
just like
we
it's not that's not the hill robin tran
who is a trans comedian has one of the
fucking best jokes ever um she was on
the road with me for a while she's
brilliant she just did that letterman
interview show and she's first of all
she's like i'm the laziest trans person
on the planet she goes my uh my email
address is still robert tran at
gmail.com
she's like i know it's like i'm not that
trans i'm gonna change my like get a new
password and then she's like the reason
um because she's vietnamese and she's
like the reason that white trans women
are so
like like um entitled i think is what
you said is because they became a double
minority overnight yeah they had white
male privilege and now so it's like a
lot of what we you know all my all my
trans girlfriends are like people are
meeting me i'm like yeah welcome to
being a woman bitch but this is how it
goes and that's like they make fun of us
they hate us and here's what i'm saying
the the hatred of trans women is don't
get it twisted it's a hatred of women
agreed it is a hatred of women period so
when and here's my other thing with
trans women people like these trans
women they they're just challenging us
i'm like
let us this is our let us handle it so
don't they're women now they're women
this is our problem and we will we will
fucking do our mean girl shit with them
they will get humbled very quickly like
i guess that's why it bothers me when
you see this rush of like 60 plus men
put out special after special after
special i don't like chunks yeah with
chunks yeah of material about it because
you're like but comedy with older guys i
believe becomes a bravery contest you've
already proved you're funny you can
already get applause breaks it's not
enough for your addiction now you have
to get well that's you either die young
and a genius a lot of times like a lot
of these really i think big comics it's
a lot of like i'm gonna do the thing
everyone's too afraid to do yeah but not
the good ones they're just trying to
impress their other big you don't have
to be like that though because the good
ones to me like like
we all i don't hear david spade's
fucking trans shit well he's a trans
woman i know which is why he's so good
no like i david is like to me like
possibly the best like i to sit in a
room with him and hear him
and just be in a restaurant with him is
like the funniest thing ever ever i've
only been like
on the periphery of it you know and like
yeah i don't
every time i see him he makes me laugh
online or in in person and he rarely has
to do anything of that nature here's my
favorite this is one of my i love like a
showbiz moment i feel like we're old
enough now to like have those moments
that you get like it makes me feel like
but i was waiting to see if a tv show
was gonna get picked up and there was a
time where you like didn't know for like
two weeks and you're waiting and he was
on
like till death or one of those shows
where he made it
lax yeah whatever and so um that was a
show there was a show called lax that
was lax to l.a to vegas right well there
was one just called lax with heather
locklear and she ran the airport i
believe that was david i drove to van
nuys six or seven times to try to play
her assistant
imagine going to the airport as your
daily job like as an actor
it's like i've already dreamed this hell
once literally i i would rather just
work at tsa it looks more fun than like
pretend like and so um
uh he said he he we were texting about
something i don't know we were gonna
maybe do something together and and we
we met in person maybe but he called me
and he's like it was one of us he just
reached out proactively
i'm not blonde so i knew anyone fuck me
and he's like hey have you heard
anything and i was like no and he was
like here's the deal with hollywood
bad news travels slow
no one wants to give you the bad news
yeah when that's good news everyone's
like you know when the ratings come in
they're great you're getting calls to 5
a.m because everyone wants to deliver
you the good news but when there's bad
news everyone's like did you call
trading trading trading calls trading
trading so he's like
we both are getting bad news and it was
like the kindest thing because he just
was like this has happened to me a
million it just was like
it was so
thoughtful and helpful and he probably
has no idea how big of a deal that was
to me but it really was because i
everyone in your life tries to like keep
your hopes up yeah but he just for no
reason yeah no dan levy did something
like that for me
after our show got canceled and because
i was like really down and i was like
because i was like
it's just i've had so many and and and
that show think at this point so i'm so
sorry to you i'm so sorry to be rude to
you to try to
make me feel better i'm like such i'm
like i'm like an asshole to try to be no
please like i i mean it's weird because
i had this journalist once say to me
this journalist was like so how do you
feel about the fact that your show only
went 43 episodes or something i was like
that's a fucking lot that is a lot i was
like
you know there was nothing more to do
there yeah and like two seasons that's a
success like we i mean in england they
do six episodes six episodes faulty
towers was what three seasons of eight
episodes like i think that we have this
thing what did you want to go for 12
years someone asked me about this uh
when i the other day when i was starting
promoting and they were like so this is
a travel show um do you think you'll act
again
and i was like excuse me what like
uh i'm acting like i can fucking
tolerate your presence right now
this is
acting and they're like no i mean like
do you think he'll go into hosting and i
was like
what are you talking about like does is
everybody that has a podcast now uh a
host no it's like this is no different
than that is no different there's this
thing where yeah i mean i think that
it's like once you do one thing you
can't go back it's like i'm always like
look at nick cannon motherfucker he's
doing movies he's hosting things he's
doing the easter parade he's doing
commercials and he's making time to have
fresh kids dude he's got 90 kids so it's
like yeah it's in alec baldwin at that
time i remember he was someone that i
was looking to he's like he's doing talk
shows he's doing script he's doing
movies the only thing that anyone would
care about is if i shot someone and i
don't see that happening
even by accident on a movie set i would
say me shooting someone is so far from
the realm of possibility
okay this is the story i was gonna tell
i'm trying to figure out how to tell
without naming names without naming
names so
there was a time when you would be put
through such a fucking ringer um to try
to get a job and a lot of it was just
mind games the director like liked to
watch you like
grovel and bang and crazy shit and i was
trying to think of what you were saying
before about like this person don't want
to cast me because i'm i'm this and i'm
that and i'm not gay and i'm not but
also just to be clear
you know guys too there was a time where
we didn't get cast because the boss
didn't want to fuck us oh yeah like
there's bigger there's a lot of problems
here this is this is a business that was
built on the back of a five-year-old
child named shirley temple it was
problematic it was it let's not pretend
like just now it's getting wild like
this is a boundaryless sick
and
so i was auditioning for this director
for this big movie that alec baldwin was
in
and yeah i mean you'll figure out what
it is but um i auditioned for it and was
this another one where you were
auditioning for a bear
this is the hunt
shouldn't the bear be less attractive
[Laughter]
she's great that's not what i was
thinking
[Laughter]
let me have a word with her in my
trailer
i'm gonna talk to the bear
and are you okay
this is the one you can't do that i'm
sorry get your microphone away from you
stop it
my alec boys gave me government
one time i ate an almond on the show we
lost like five thousand fucking
topher grace ate a chicken sandwich and
it was like we had to
crawl our way back i have that tattoo
of topher grace eating a chicken
sandwich
[Laughter]
it's big
that's huge
my whole back
the fact that they had to put on 70s
clothes every day for seven years is so
funny to me
the fact that they're in the chair like
it's still the 70s can it be the 80s by
now i found they're still doing this
hairstyle um
okay so alec baldwin comes so this i'm
auditioning for this director
it's kind of clear i'm not getting it
and he's just kind of like
i have to fly to boston to do another
audition i'm flying to boston no on my
own dime he's like come read with me in
person here i read with him here i get
to it's his production office so they're
already shooting the movie someone's
clearly already got this job
there's a call sheet like i'm not up for
this
and he goes um
i show you not i do the scene which is a
dumb scene it's literally like so who
are you dating you're never gonna date
it you know you need a makeover right
yeah
i know this part i am the shrill judy
greer i got it and um and he goes do it
again
and your favorite color's purple go
and i remember being like
like i did the same ex truly exact thing
and just was like okay think of purple i
was like this guy's making me better
he's making me better okay got it and
then it was do it again and your
sister's in the hospital i'm like 90
sure my sister was actually
at the
it's a total number i go home completely
demoralized like you're such a piece of
shit like you're never gonna get like
making this business like whatever and
then alec baldwin i heard from people
that were working on the movie alec
baldwin came on the set
and he came in like a weekend they'd
already been filming and the director
was pulling a lot of that shit with the
actors it was they do one take and
and so alex baldwin goes and does his
first take it's a giant wide shot of
like a monologue it's like a classic
alec baldwin kind of role and he gives
this big monologue and literally the
crew like claps like it's like one of
those where yeah yeah where you know you
just hit it off
and then um let's say the director's
name is adam palley okay great so
after his amazing take director adam
palley goes up to alec baldwin and is
like uh
you like whispering his ears
just giving him all these notes
goes back to sit and adam pally goes
back to sit and chair and alec baldwin
just turns to the whole crew and goes
adam pally
director
or obstacle
i think to the
entire crew
and the director and like
never know
like it was over and i remember like
it's bad that i've heard that story now
you have oh no what no no it's bad that
i i'm now armed with that story as i go
into my next job because i'm gonna be
like let me tell you a story about alex
baldwin
um okay i wanna ask you a couple things
okay really quick about this show where
else besides richmond do you have a
national creation connection
they forgive you they forgive me puerto
rico is like
the best miami um i think we we didn't
go to one like club in miami and had the
best time i feel like miami is uh gets a
bad rap
you know because people feel like it's
like this
deluge of south beach it's like almost
vegas style rap but it's really fun
cocaine and but that's america yeah
that's true there's cocaine everything
it's just like anti-semitism it is
everywhere ubic um and i like that and
then um
i'll tell you where i didn't love
say where i don't need to go back to and
without like alienating anybody it's pr
that's what we do here that's our brand
probably fine because i don't think
anybody who is born there stays israel
well i can't right now
i just uh i fall on the other side of
that no uh
uh portland
you're not alone i found portland oregon
to be like i was all psyched for it
people like you're gonna love it and
then i got there and i was like what am
i gonna love about this like they hate
me if you don't like
love
like waiting for coffee for like 45
minutes yeah like they get to it when
they get if you're gonna do portland the
portland way i was dating someone who
lived in portland for like two years i
would go up there all the time and i
remember being like i get to like
rewrite it i'm off on script i have a
month to write a script i'm like what do
people do that have jobs you order a
coffee they're making it like they're
dripping it money doesn't make anything
go round the guy's like doing finishing
his hacky sack game and you're like can
i just get my coffee like who has this
time i had a conversation reporting
legit we landed on a sunday and i went
out and like the town was like
toast nothing was open on a sunday yeah
and i was like it's religious or
something so i was like asking the
coffee shop like seems kind of dead and
they're like yeah sundays are really
different aspergers they're like sundays
are really dead people go out pretty
hard on saturday so sundays are kind of
it's like oh so they close the stores
yeah a lot of them yeah it's like well
do you think this place will be open
tomorrow like monday is kind of like
monday's kind of tough it's like kind of
like a second sunday
and i was like
well then wouldn't it be sun
do they work did people work he's like
yeah people work but it's like
tough i was like well what about
tuesdays like tuesday second monday
i was like what is this fucking city
like it's everyone home but this is a
store i'm out of
stores open the door
i need like beaten statues yeah like
where it's just money money doesn't
matter in portland people truly are like
i'll get to it when i get to it but yeah
i mean i i mean fred armistead and kerry
brownstein did such an amazing job i
feel like of uh
satirizing portland but it is so
funny how
um
not exaggerated that is no in fact like
i find i found it to be almost like
reality in a lot of ways like stuff
would outshine it like you know like a
store where there's birds on everything
like that's almost like boring for
portland now yeah yeah yeah yeah like
portland's like no no everything's a
bird yeah yeah yeah
like what it's like no the table's made
out of bird bones it's like this is a
bird this is a bird you're in a bird
it's like
you know we're all birds it's like we're
all starting
it's like oh cool how's the business
doing terribly
terrible we make no money it's like well
how do you afford this amazing things
like that we don't know this is there's
no water electricity it's like we don't
know what's going on well what happens
if something bad happens can i call the
police they don't work there's nothing
bad happens like what happens if the
thing goes on fire it's like run because
there's no fire department
no paramedics
and weed caused a dime weed is so cheap
the best part about it is they think
you're trash oh they
you're disgusting someone yelled at me
to go back to california i was like
that's anti-semitic
that is i
i'm not from california
you're saying that because you think
there's a camera following me and you
think i'm a hollywood jew
so like go back to california but i'm
not from california because they like
didn't want filming in their cities yes
and they were like we were like when i
think about people from portland i think
you guys want no attention yeah that's
what happens when i look at your eyes
meanwhile the guy has like gauges
through every orifice
why are you rolling up your jeans this
to an inch is there a flood coming is it
because
i cannot fuck you if i picture you
rolling two rolls it's so i can see
yourself i don't know how anyone fucks
in portland and yet there's like um
dearth of strip clubs
like you can't walk in portland without
like if you're on your phone looking
down you're like i'm so sorry you look
up it's like someone on nine inch
stilettos with like they all have like
thrown out like armpit hair and like
c-section scars no they all look like an
american apparel it's like all like
suicide girl like american apparel like
yeah old thing and you like well
everyone's like everyone's just like
walking from one strip club to another
there's like one strip club that's vegan
and one that's me and they're across the
street from each other it's like the
whole thing i was just like it feels
like no supervision like it feels like
everybody like the dorks took over yeah
there's no problem yes there's like all
the cool kids went to california
so all like the raging dorks are like
don't come in here
little girl's allowed there's my trip
yeah like oh no you can't come in here
unless you're dressed like a forger
we make all our silverware ourselves and
if you can't get down with that go back
to california
i was just like all right i'm going back
to go by the way because it's also the
men the boots they all wear are it's the
one brand red wing the red wing boots
they're they're the platforms are
literally two inches all the men are
just in heels it's like they short guys
can wear heels and it's like no but i'm
a lumberjack you know what portland is
it is
adults larping yeah i i felt it was like
it had big divorce energy
because like when people get divorced
sometimes they like they're like you
know what that was the old me
you know that was carter when carter was
married to rebecca but the new carter
doesn't even like pickleball
the new carter the noob carter pickles
watermelon yeah the new carter is doing
it all from the earth
the new carter can't even finish this
conversation because he's got to go feed
his starters that's right
yeah and rebecca i don't know what she's
doing i hope she's happy with dale
i can't i could not
i ima portland to me is you're hooking
up with a guy and he's like i gotta go i
gotta feed my sourdough
and you're like
can't do it this is like the amount of
um
transportation in portland personal
transportation with wheels
is
is
far exceeds any city but then when you
see how different the size of those
wheels are and how difficult those
wheeled objects are to ride you're like
who who wanted this no one has a bike
everyone's like everyone's got like um
uh
uh recreation um devices on the top of
their car yeah it's like skis it's like
snow and everyone watches every bike is
like one giant wheel one tiny wheel you
need a ladder to get on or it's like a
unicycle or it's a pogo stick or it's
like no one
no it's i've never seen so many wheels
no one's got a car or the one that you
just it's one wheel and it's two feet
yeah the only cars i saw in portland
were on fire and you're like how but
there's no lime scooters or no there's
nothing
the lie went in there was like don't
worry about portland
no one's got a phone
there's no point everyone's got their
own scooter in portland you should move
to portland dan the guy that teaches you
guitar in new york
because i feel like those those pole
flyers would do great it's like theater
teachers and like people that are like
really into the fermentation process
yeah and that takes a long time this is
boring yeah but it's i i it was here's
why i can't this is what this is
portland i have i have a lot of love for
portland but this is where this is the
real thing that annoys me
are you how do you um the comedian oh i
i don't have a tv
okay you just knew me
so you
portland has like my ivy league cousin's
energy why are you acting like you're uh
like amish and impoverished like you've
you've seen tv yeah you you've you've
wha you'd have it's like oh that's cool
you're communion you're playing down
downtown so what are you like filling a
hole with laughs
like oh that's what you need oh that's
cool me i'm a farmer
i'm an urban farmer i've taken i found
an old fedex truck that was abandoned
and i seeded it and now i farm in the
middle of the city and i'm a doula and i
allow women to come and give birth
so if you think i would love to catch
out your what your little show
but i but like portland is also not a
big comedy person yeah not a big
comedy's not a big like for the amount
of comedians that like come down here
from there they get out pretty fast yeah
they they know like this is humorless
they're like people yeah there's
that was a thing i think i rubbed up
against that's what it is like
people take themselves so seriously that
it's hard to like goose them which is
fine if that's your thing but they're
all in one there's no one to look to be
like
like you can't check in with any
everyone's on the same page yeah about
the costume which is written in like
invisible ink and if you make a joke
you're a bully yeah you're exactly and
you're like you guys
what are we you're all wearing like neon
orange socks with like like what are
like and you're rolling your pants up so
i can see them i see them what you
wanted me to do right that's but i'm not
allowed to make fun of that like you
didn't you want me to see these songs no
like crowd work in portland sounds like
a hell of its own creation like being
like what's everyone
what does everyone do here it's like
you know what don't tell them what do
you do for work
work is a social contract yeah like work
what do i do for survival
i live off the land
yeah that is it and then where else did
you go that you liked um i really like
how many cities total we did eight in
season one um how did you decide the
cities you were gonna go we tried to do
like a high low swath of america we
tried to like
get to places that
people want to see so like if you are
watching it you're like oh i would like
to go to maui you know that is a
destination i'd like to go to but then
they would also be like i never thought
of richmond virginia yeah that is a cool
place the same way like
we tried to do puerto rico which was
like
i don't think gets as much
love for the city of san juan and puerto
rico as it should i mean that city now
that it's one percent taxes
logan paul lives there well yeah now
well now there's like yeah crypto stuff
but
it is
old san juan is like
way better than charleston and it's got
that same vibe of like people in bars
and like the city streets and the
cobblestones and the food is amazing and
like
it's
puerto rico just like hit me in a good
in a good spot
i like this place yeah that's great um
and yeah i mean every place was fun i
mean america is interesting right now
it's like i mean every state feels like
a different country to me i mean you're
just i just did whatever 70 cities or
something and you're just like
how like minnesota i was like this is
like a chocolate village this is like a
chocolate christmas village and then you
go to florida and you're like what the
it's just we have so many climates we
have so many different the only thing
that is consistent is the aesthetic of
uh new construction
houses houses like everything looks like
toronto in the in america it's a
simulation but we're in a simulation yes
but you see it when you like get out in
the in in america and you're like flying
into denver looks exactly the same as
flying into miami which looks exactly
the same as flying into dallas
cul-de-sac it's like suburbs yes it's
like it and the buildings that go up
they all look exactly the same all glass
yeah they're all like you know it it
just feels like america in even in all
of its new climates the the
capitalism of america is like flattening
well you know we're running out of sand
is that true
we're running out of sand i thought
water was the problem
sand don't we have enough sand fake news
i don't want to fuck up your day emily
hit me we're running out of scenes
running out of sand
i know where there's a lot of it
where
the desert
i'm here
can anyone tell everyone to
tell someone to go look in the desert
it's like that sam kenneth invented
we're all gonna have to start
surrendering our hourglasses
i know it's here somewhere
i know you have a pictionary that was a
tiny timer
you're hiding it in the floor
oh emily did you find it what did find
what about running out of scenes there's
a shortage of sand because of the water
problem so
yes so the raising rising sea levels
caused by climate change contribute to
the shortage well it's also you build
with sand and china basically has
extended their country i mean they build
an airport on the water i mean
like i went to hong kong and we landed
and they're like this is artificial land
landing in hong kong is terrifying right
because you land you go through the
mountains and then you come into the the
buildings like right on you and you land
in the water
on an airport in the water yes that was
man-made yeah it's terrifying and then
um there's can you there's in i think
it's india there's such a demand for
sand that there is like basically a sand
like
i'm gonna say indentured servitude
system where they send people out of the
ocean to get sand and then they just
leave them
in the ocean india's sand problem in the
fore as the u.n reports of crisis
uh
from my blog every news article is from
me
i'm on whitneycomingstock.com
man this is i'm gonna leave here taking
a whole new look and here's what i'll
say when i ph i by the way like starting
a podcast for me i was it was very like
i was like you ha i know i have to do
this i don't think i'm good at it i
don't oh i'm not that
like
oh what
yeah i'm sorry a lot of this applies to
india where sand extraction is a major
environmental problem both legal and
illegal sand mining destabilizes
riverbanks and renders them prone to
floods the demand for sand is is driven
by rapid urbanization and construction
boom miners both loosely organized
groups and better organized mafias
that control the extraction of the sand
from rivers and coasts are not uncommon
workers activists journalism journalists
have been killed if they oppose the
activity that is it's like a real
problem because sand is what glass is
made of yeah and we're moving away from
plastic
we're running out of sand and global
demand could soar 45 percent by 2060
humanities appetite for sand could soar
45 within four decades according to
researchers who say unchecked
consumption risk environmental damage
and shortages of key material for urban
expansion because sand is made by water
it's like rivers like make it can we
make the glass out of something else
look let's call shark tank i can get us
on shark tank we don't have the solution
but we have the pro what if we built
what if we built the glass out of shitty
trans jokes
we got enough of those what if we got
the portlanders on we got a lot of
shitty trans jokes i think we could
build a whole building
maybe we could fix the on-house problem
this is another topic that jerry loves i
have all these things i know i have to
let you go soon can i just really
quickly please i'm i'm here say
uh i have a hot tape this is maybe the
hottest steak i've had
uh but which is this place uh 101 places
to party before you die you've only done
10 but there will be 101. that's why we
called it that we were like
i was literally like
try to cancel this shit motherfucker
even if you do i'm a winner
syndicated
places to party yes
um
to your point i think part of the reason
people loved anthony bourdain so much is
because it was just kind of a he was
just wandering in a restaurant he was
wandering into places he wasn't like
pushing an agenda of like an arc or
anything but i also argue that that show
i found i i i think he's very hot i i
just find him kind of glib
and dismissive personally that's just my
could be my thing with just men being
like watching someone sli slave over
food for 10 hours like pretty good and
you're just like okay could you if
people welcome you into their home can
you like fake that
but you're it's like to me
i've been waiting for the bourdain
that's just goes for jokes yes we that
was our big thing was like we
i feel like a lot of food shows are like
that and so we had the
the nice thing that we did was there's
two of us so we are always the butt of
the joke
which is like i think
i think that's what makes it different
than the the other travel shows because
like the other travel shows a lot of
times it's like
the joke the fun of the culture which is
like how we don't it's like oh well it's
this is how uh you know i love action
bronson but it's like this is how action
bronson travels and it's really
different than the way you travel and
like you know i think that sometimes
that like
gets a little boring yeah in a way in
ways not that not action process but
like just just that format and so by
having two of us
and getting to improvise and make up
scenes like what we would do is we'd go
into a restaurant
and sit down and we'd start talking the
wait or whatever but really what we were
going for was like a scene so
sit down and be like
god like things got out of hand last
night or whatever be like start talking
about this sandwich really like this is
good hangover food why am i hungover
it's like and then that's where the like
red meat was was as soon as you stopped
being like what's the history of this
place yeah and you started being like i
have gi issues because by the way here's
the problem
everyone can google anything you're not
breaking news on a tv show these places
it's like if people want to know they'll
know yeah and and that's why it's like
it's way more fun and funnier for the
audience
to like see us do bits as like many bits
as you can so like we put out a clip
some someone asked like what is the show
about and the only clip we had was this
bit of us at a this like famous ice
cream shop in denver that is like
it's so kitschy it like looks like a vat
of milk ice cream we don't mention it
once we're sitting in front of it and
the whole bit is about how liam neeson
has all these images on line of uh like
uh pea stains on his pants
and it's liam neeson who said like
yes that liam neeson yes
and he but it's true and then we like
start googling it great and then that
turned into a run of like how many
podcast fun parts
exactly it's like and then it turned
into how many puns can you get of liam
neeson movies where he's like pissing
finally ending on schindler's piss is
like the big it's like it's so easy and
nice and fun and then the bits of the
songs yeah from around his rose is great
i don't know if liam neeson was in
batman 3. we had like qui-gon urine um
taking a piss
[Laughter]
i forget liam neeson his career is tough
it's like taken
i just did that one oh sorry
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
blonde on the premises
by the way cold pursuit that would have
just been mine cold piss
cold pissed soon
but there is but even more disturbing
than this google image liam neeson piss
pants
i'm serious this is
we are being the bullies no we're not
that dude's awful
yeah you're right yeah
don't worry we put it in the show
no this this can't be right it's real
why but wait why look at the look at the
volume of it the fact that they're
blurring the guy he's talking to his
face the volume of the amount of
pictures
look at but that's only one that's only
one but hold on guys sometimes when guys
pee and they shake their dicks and
there's like a little spot my man likes
to drink
that's cool so this is someone that is
drunk and pissed himself or like didn't
shake all the way i mean
you're scrolling through multiples yeah
wait are we is this four that's four
you're not even deep yet no i'm there is
a janice dick and the reason i learned
about it because gabriel's told me that
he read janice dickinson's book and she
talks about it in her book
uh this is shocking it's shocking i know
only one of the things you'll learn
honestly here obviously crazy all my
friends that i think are the meanest
people i now think that they're pussies
because no one's the fact that none of
my friends have sent me this is wild how
is this not
yeah real like world knowledge well it's
about to be next week
[Music]
is this someone who's inebriated and
just pisses himself or is this a power
move i don't know i mean
i haven't given it much thought since i
came up with i have a very specific set
of skills
i can completely piss my pants i have a
very specific set of skills and one
specific lack of a skill
i know this you only asked me for my
positives but there it isn't wrong
i don't need to be under the bed for
this call at all
but
i piss myself
they just were like going to the bed we
don't know there's quite an echo in that
room what are you doing that i've had
you on the phone i'm in the restroom
i can't do two things at once where's my
daughter
whoops
i'm at bloomies i'm buying new traffic
if you must know i'm having a prostate
exam because i found that i have a
problem
in not the best way either i was
watching a travel show
he's never googled himself
he thinks you're the only two people
that know about it i just landed in
brussels
i didn't know what to watch i was a
little jet-lagged
[Laughter]
turn on the television these two fat gay
bears
screaming
screaming about my my pissing my pants
but they were white so it was fine i
listened cause one was white and
catholic
the other was swarthy and semitic the
other was a hebe the other i'm searching
for in the night
i'll find it one day
you know you won't find him the urinal
and i'll waste no time looking even if i
have to pee
[Laughter]
emily is hanging by a thread you know
it's not
bowl and branch sheets they are the best
sheets possible the best threads
possible
i love them i take sheets with me on the
road when i travel they're on all my
beds it's a game changer yeah they come
in nine neutral colors which is the
total amount of colors in this house
outside of this room yes which is
perfect i don't like silly goose colors
i'm not my sleeping isn't a joke to me
okay sheets aren't a joke to me okay i
go from twin to california king get your
sheet together you'll immediately feel
the difference of their iconic signature
sheets they're 100 free from toxins
meaning no pesticides formaldehyde or
other harsh chemicals and no bed bugs
bowl and branch sheets fit the deepest
of mattresses and are labeled with top
and bottom tags so making your bed is
easier than ever
changing insanely it's so helpful the
annual summer event is over but bowl and
branch extended our code for exclusive
access to 20 off through the end of the
month with promo code whitney at
bowlingbranch.com this is their best
offer of the year before the holidays so
act now that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com you know what homo code
whitney for 20 off
i just feel like this is a very good
gift for kids going back to college oh
college great idea yeah going back to
school there's nothing better than new
crisp sheets to pretend you're a
different person yeah you're gonna be on
a shitty mattress and then nothing
happened last year happened
how many different text chains do you
have with people where you send them
britney spears shit because i i think i
have like two to three groups of friends
where she'll do something and i'll send
it to him and be like what's going on
like post liberation
or yeah like post-liberation or
pre-liberation like she's she's we let
her out too soon she's a constant injury
yes do we yeah did we make a mistake no
because girls are acting like that i
know that that's it i didn't go through
that no and that's why we did it but it
does have a little bit of like when you
when you like um
like say goodbye to the pet at the end
of the movie you know it's like go on
now
go anywhere
don't give me that look get on and out
there
oh come on brit like don't do this to me
we said that you're gonna go out there
in the woods and she's like looking back
she's like
looking and then she finally takes one
step and gets like her brain's blown out
by a hunter
the bear from the remnant the bear from
the remnant alec baldwin it's like
whoops we're going to scream
oh my god horrible how could this happen
twice
when did you become a dvd i don't know i
thought she was the dp
that was britney spears
shit
[Laughter]
i i
i find her writing to be troublesome
like to me the actions in the posts are
like that second banana
to the real to the real problem which is
her
her use of the pen
[Laughter]
because spaces
you know you are
you're an ingrate
we have britney spears trashing her
sister she's crashing her mother
i will take a whatever i can get i love
it
i love it and i love honestly like the
nudity is is a blessing like because
like my whole like when i was a kid i'd
be like i wonder what she looks like
naked it's like now i know now you know
but but it is is great but at the same
time
her her
her tongue
seems to
get her in trouble sometimes like she'll
write things that like maybe code like
sometimes she'll be like i'm having so
much fun help me help me help me help me
help me help me help me help me just
kidding i don't think she totally knows
like also she's been so sequestered i'm
not sure if she knows how like what
emojis she's like having eggplant for
dinner
yeah like are you sucking jack yeah
you're like no she's like just at a thai
restaurant eating eggplant eggplant but
then she is also at the same time like i
do mean dick like you're like so what
what are you talking about like it's so
difficult because she is like she will
post like
she does that is that is like you'll see
you'll see a uh instagram for her like
totally naked and she'll be like she's
like i went out for dinner last night
with sam emoji eggplant eggplant
eggplant i both had eggplant and dick
like it's like well what am i saying
vaccinates from very infantilized and
like innocent to like brutally asexual
and for realsies yeah it should be like
yesterday sammy brought me my baby
bottle full of my favorite margarita and
women's rights are being taken from us
like well
i've ever heard yeah also my babies hate
me so what's the difference
like what what
just have to have the kid and in 20
years decide if you want them or not
yeah it's like we i i say we can have
abortions up until they're 21.
just ask kevin fairmont
just ask haley and casey yeah yeah
who are they my sons
my sons that we thought were girls we
gave them girls names i don't have time
to i don't have time to talk to them
because i'm putting up another christmas
tree in my living room i know it was the
craziest thing when i was liberated i
found i had sons i thought they were
daughters
i thought i had beautiful blonde girls
running around yeah i'll tell you the
problem i'm going to tell you the
problem the problem is that she is still
wearing the same clothes she's wearing
the peasant tops and and it's it's this
um
she's still doing that coquettish like
i'm just in these little peasant tops
and i'm this little milkman yeah she's
40.
she's my age she's 40.
it's really obvious
like those are no i think that's what
happens when you're 14
and like you're just got through puberty
and some
like jabba the hutt motherfucker is like
sweetheart
put on his uh church outfit
dance around
plaid screen
oh it's gonna be millions i look back i
mean i did go to catholic school for a
couple years and i look back and i
i'm very like water under the bridge
bitch but i'm like
that was so sexual like you didn't know
we were wearing uh plaid skirts and we
would roll them up and like
you just were like i'm um fuck these and
you're like oh that was like so sexy to
so many people i like didn't know i was
participating in a weird fetish beyond
that you're dressing up for like the
people like the fact that that is a i
thought i was in the craft yeah but the
fact that that is i was in a porn a
thing where it's like there's like these
priests going around being like
how high is your skirt
it's like all very like weird it's like
no no no no no too high
like all so weird looking at all it's
like yeah
the other day i noticed miss whitney
that when you crossed your legs i saw a
little bit of your white panties it's
like shut the fuck what
you're like the principal
i need to spank you with a ruler
meanwhile at jewish school it's like
cover yourself put a wig on you're
fucked through a sheet you fuck through
a sheet don't look at anybody
don't touch anybody hide the schnoz
kiddo
go get a calculator and learn how to
work the worst part you got to turn the
lights out of using the sheet otherwise
there's a shadow
it's like well what are we looking at
ghosts on the wall
come on i'm here for the business
she turns into a kkk hood very important
i know but when it's behind the light
you can really see my doctor my god my
my captain hook you know
there's nothing funnier to me than being
a jewish woman who's just like has to
fuck through a sheet and the leg comes
on and she's just like
[Laughter]
look it's funny
it's funny
it's funny no put your shirt open go
home would you smack them to a home
we're gonna need a bigger boat we're
gonna need a bigger boat
jaws we're gonna need a bigger boat now
where you going you're going after the
nightclub again
what do you and your friends do down at
that nightclub
oh my god please tell me jewish women do
that on tick tock
please tell me that's a good thing i
hope that's a sex yeah just like that
like you're pranking the guys
women doing interpretive uh dick sucking
with puppets i just like the idea of
like like shadow animals just biting his
dick it's like peter rabbit like oh shit
they're like a little clarinet please
like
she's sucking his dick
like a deer in the floor
i can't find a hole
are these the fitted sheets
i need some fitted sheets
wait is this the mattress cover
springing back why is this
one that has the elastic that covers the
mattress the idea that i guess we'll use
this and it just it just keeps like
closing in on you you're trying to find
this is from the hospital marvin
i took it with me after you
[Music]
yeah
this is wax paper from the reuben
well it slides right off
all right so i think i've cancelled both
of us
that's what podcasts are yeah yeah it's
trying to get cancer if you're if you
leave a little worried there's only net
loss in doing podcasts
like what did you do today i tried to
fuck my career
like no it's literally like i dare you
it's d you're double daryl
and the more fucked up i do you know say
looking at the camera the more fucked up
the thing i say i look into the camera
i'm like fucking i need a fucking week
off so bad please come for me
i'm like the guy that wore the dress
trying to get sent home i'm like what do
i have to say cancel me i'll win an
oscar the kind of shit that i say in the
pack i mean i literally get a call from
like the head of universal because i was
doing a movie with foo fighters and we
like shot it i'd like sign nine
documents saying like you can't tell
anyone about this movie
i guess not i'm like i just did a food
fight it's a horror movie
they're like what are you doing i was
like oh i like forget
like the people but i all i also do hate
that people are so far up their ass like
i'm going to shoot uh this thing
next week and like the amount of
watermarks like i'm like can i just get
sides can i see what i have to say
they're like you'll see when you get to
canada
i'm like okay well how am i supposed to
work on this shit if you he's like well
we don't wanna if someone gets a hold of
this script like
the this script then you should hire
them because they'll know how to perform
it yeah cause like hire them i am i
they'll know more about the character
than i do maybe i'm not like fully in
the news
like as much as i want but i
i don't remember the big story about the
michael b jordan leak
of a script maybe i'm like confusing it
with
abortion becoming illegal but like i
i don't know if hollywood's up its own
ass or like what but like this tara read
straight to video movie is not the new
iphone model i'm sorry you're fine if
someone leaves a script at a bar sorry
episode five and six of the wesley
snipes netflix show
is under high security
oh okay we it can't i have to go to the
director's house to read the script also
by the way you're gonna put and then
this also they'll water market they'll
put your name across it and i'm like
dude i would if i saw like a random
script like at a starbucks on the floor
never pick it up
if it said whitney cummings that's how
whitney comes i would be like what the
fuck is whitney doing that yeah yeah
shit it's a big part it's just no but
they want it to be like if it leaks it's
your fault
but that's i'm like don't you just
fucking email it to me that's that's
what's all in
ugh
it doesn't matter so many grievances to
fire with hollywood
but it's also like it's a bunch of big
precious babies like we're all precious
babies when you're making a movie you're
like think it's the most important thing
in the world and if you don't what are
you doing well i will say i i i
not to toot my own horn but i i knew
when i was making dirty grandpa it was
not the most important thing in the
whole the fact that mandzukic was like
nah dude oh
i
there's a lot of people in this business
that
if if i see them out and we have a good
conversation i'm like
you're nailing a girl like you're like
you it's like lee eisenberg yeah there's
a couple people where it's like bj novak
yeah if i kate like cape orland chelsea
peretti yeah there's a couple people
where i'm like her you better not yeah
mandzukis if i can
have like a conversation with him and
not completely feel like
i should throw myself off a bridge
afterwards i'm like he's one like if he
was disappointed anything i did like
overtly i don't think i'd recover he was
my improv teacher when i was 19. so i've
been disappointing him for a long time
he
in fact i he one time told me that i was
so bad
at improv and i had been in his class
like a year and i was like why he's like
because you can't act
it's like you're not acting you're a bad
actor
i was like what
i love that men can just talk to each
other like that yeah
if he said
you're a bad actor you're writing you're
trying to be funnier than everybody but
you're not that smart
and i was like thank you
19 like just moved back to new york
but we like so i've been disappointed
for a long time but we were both cast in
this movie as adults and friends
and so
it was like a fun time you know like we
both on the same flight down to atlanta
you know what i mean but did he not read
this great like everyone knew everyone
it wasn't in this group it was like
funny
when was james franco in cornrows
can we stay focused spring break spring
breakers but that was a i think a
different he could be canceled for a lot
that was late but that doesn't mean it
didn't happen no but it was like his had
like beads
yeah
mine didn't have beads but it was only
for a sound it was cornrows like it's no
way around it like you would never
look at that image now and be like i
don't know what that is like i know what
i know what that is so why did adele
why's it i mean she got in trouble but
i'm often asking why adele and not me
but i
i it was just like one of those things
where we were all psyched and then we
went to the table reading table you know
obviously because table reads when
there's like the beginning of the movie
everyone's so hyped sucking their own
dicks they're all psyched i was like
this movie's gonna be a fucking
massive hit
massive with de niro
ephron massive hit
and everyone's like joking around we
were having fun i can't believe we're in
this like movie together it's so fun so
weird to be like buddies and we're in
this movie of scenes together it's so
fun next day was my fitting
someone made the idea what have you even
courtrooms like a white rapper or
something like what if what if
come back that night and it was like oh
shit now i can't hang out no we can't go
out to dinner
it's such a but the problem is like once
there's a big swing like that everyone's
so you can't you can't you can't back
out no because no one knows who made the
decision right and no one wants to and
everyone thinks it was someone else so
no one takes initiative no one will just
be like um
no one knows who to ask because there's
too many cooks in the kitchen at this
point and truly the way it happened was
just like the character was crazy and
everyone was like crazy or crazy or
crazy to the point where like someone
made that decision someone's like yes
and you're like i don't know what's
happening
all right yes yes
the next thing you know i'm in atlanta
checking into my hotel with a do-rag on
the guy was like are you okay sir
i i just did the the machine gun kelly
movie and the character was like
despicable and it was a lot of
uh it was a lot of improv because it was
ep davidson's in it and it was just like
f like f but i on the press store was
like it was not improv uh it was not it
was written script because it's like
everything we improv i'm like no you
don't want to because all of my shit is
so ignorant it's like she's a super
ignorant like hollywood
agent or something no you don't want him
like can we not say that i came up with
one yeah i like to go like this did not
they encouraged me he's like neil labute
like to the world
neil
[Laughter]
um wait okay i'm gonna have to see now
everyone's gonna go watch this movie
i never saw it but i feel like it did
well no
no no no no it did not do well i just
want to be clear we have to end this uh
because i need to check my pussy for a
giant red ring
um i did have a tick
bite my the crevice next to my vagina
like the
and um i did start antibiotics this
morning
lyme disease is tough
can i tell you something all i do is
make fun of celebrities who just their
movies not doing well so they have to
like announce that they have lyme
disease and now that i i've made fun of
it for so long now yeah that now i i
feel like i deserve it
at least you got it from a tick eating
you out
this you gotta eat now i was thinking
about doing like a tick-tock
thing that was just me dealing with my
tank like you're fucking real bummer
not like on your ankle i do i am looking
i'm i'm currently in the market for an
excuse for my personality and if i could
say like i'm lying disease yeah that
would help i mean i know you have a
boyfriend but put yourself on tick rya
is that like the dating the dating site
cause there's a dating site for people
with herpes yes no that's how actors get
lyme disease when they want to have a
cause they like look for the right tick
for them they're like
swiping right this tick bit kate hudson
it's called
just in lime
i hate you
i'm literally just trying to think of
names of the app
don't fuck up my two dollar etsy
chocolate shop hey those are brochures i
got cte from your child
what is the name of a dating app
to match a celebrity with the right tick
we've looked up your proper science and
found the right tick for you plenty of
tech plenty plenty of time
[Laughter]
suck my dick
[Laughter]
i hate you
that's right my new calls man i'm
matthew mcconaughey my new cause man
just keep ticking just keep checking
just keep checking man
and if you're disoriented you might have
lime
and if you vote for me you don't if you
vote for me well that's on you
i'm crazy
i talk to tigers
like dialogue
they talk back
[Laughter]
well for me governor for governor let's
make texas weird
i like that i talk with tigers
no with we have a dialogue it's not
about talking to adam if you talk adam
you can't hear him
no one wants to be no one wants to be
talked at especially killer feline
they won't be hurt
what did i say about this interview
i was like this will be the funniest
podcast we've ever done oh my god i know
oh god don't let that get out you're
supposed to be a leading man
[Laughter]
who do you want to be a do you want to
be a uh uh i'm calling him kenny powers
i want to be robin williams at the end
or at least have access to a similar
window
window or window paint or hit you can't
have a pain without a window
either way you need a shade are we in
that are we talking metaphor i can't do
no
what's in his garage
was it he went he went out like the
bradley cooper character and
turn around just won't get another look
at it
that's how he went out
here's what's so weird about a lot of
these suicides oh my god and then it was
like on a doorknob and you're like
hangings and then i'm spending more time
trying to figure out like well how did
instead of just grieving it was like
when it was like kate spade
um that rush of them mick uh
well they say that it's wildly unethical
to cover suicide the way we cover
suicide through clickbait it causes
people it causes clusters there's an
amazing article in the atlantic i read
um i think it was like eight years ago
about suicide clusters in the school
that's the stanford feeder school up in
um
wherever that is and that right before
exams
someone will jump in front of it there's
a train like right by the school and
then everyone and then more people will
do it it gives them like the cornell
then cornell has like a bridge or
something right and then there's also
you're not supposed to i mean i don't
know i'm not gonna tell people what to
do with their lives i don't give a shit
um but uh you're not supposed to rest in
peace because if someone is in that
space they're like oh that's where the
piece is gonna be like it's like because
people always say like you're better now
and you you're safer now you're in a
better place you're finally in a better
place like the language that we use
we're saying like thank god you found
peace kind of thing which is like
because so many people it is amazing
one of my favorite very sinister fucked
up games of as soon as someone commits
suicide or dies picturing all the
celebrities going through their iphoto
looking for a photo of them with the
person oh god so they can be like he's
such a nice guy it really does go down
like that for real why can't why do you
have to be in the photo that's what i
always don't understand is like why
can't you just post the thing that you
liked about them then find like the
thing but i think what it does i think
they're i don't know i think it does
make people feel like it's like a
grieving thing where it's like yeah you
know
the same way that people put out
pictures of the person who died with
like their kids and stuff
when you go to the house or the like
shiva
when you go to shiva it's like pictures
of them of the person in their happiest
moments like around the house
and i feel like um
it's similar to that like people like
their own thing like they're like yeah i
worked with ray liotta for a day
rest in peace ray liotta cause they are
actually fucked up from it they're like
holy shit i guess i can die if rey died
i
am actively always looking for a cult
a religion
something something to believe in and
when my dad uh passed away a couple
years ago very suddenly very
awful as my mom was sudden and it's a
whole other thing
yes and we have a sudden club with some
of our friends yes of course and it's a
whole other they show up dude and it's
important because it is a different loss
because you
you
a loss over time gives you the mental
runway
to like
deal with your own with the
possibilities and i feel like when
someone you love dies suddenly
especially if they're not they're
younger yeah you
those it's like you can't even dwell on
the possibilities you're you're you're
you're
you didn't even know this could happen
and then you have to deal with right now
right in front of you because
and then you have to like start giving
your credit card to people yeah
and then you have to put your person you
have to deal with all of them other
things like
here's the clothes she was wearing when
she died it's like
you know it's like all this stuff
there's a level of logistics that is so
um
horrifying yeah when i was going through
the you know my my the grieving of my
dad all of my jewish friends i was like
i want to convert to do they there was a
plan yeah people showed up with food
there was that you this is how much you
grieve during this time you don't people
were showing up and just handling it and
i was like
there's no other religion has a plan in
place well we think about it constantly
because we're
i think it's similar to the the out the
allegory i don't think it is that but
like people are often like why did jews
smoke weed
why are jews such weed heads like
historically
and i think it's ptsd in that way
similarly ancestral trauma is beyond
yeah it's just it's so traumatic
to grow up
in that
element where death
the moment you are born you it is
instilled in you that people want to
kill you
like that's the first thing you're told
is that welcome people are trying to
kill you and a lot of times it's true so
it's like it's
very difficult to
operate in any other fight or flight
from the from the moment that you're
born and then when you're in utero the
epigenetic imprinting of like a woman
that is even closer yes and then and
then immediately what we do is we go
get one foot in front of the other
put that body in the ground today is it
dead
is it dead like is it breathing
then it needs to go in the ground and
then we have to put the dirt on top of
it and then we will go home and when we
get home
we will
grow our beard there will be food we're
gonna there will be a ton of food and
you will eat
and you will cry
for seven days and you won't be able to
like
go to your job to get over it and work
extra hard and you won't be able to like
go out drinking to get over it you have
to sit with it
and do it feel it and feel it and it's
hardcore they don't fuck around like
when they drop that body in the ground
it makes a thud it makes a sound that is
like
the only other sound i can equate to is
like when you hear a gunshot
like close up you know and like
you like your whole body gets like
holy shit like that's the a stark it's
like a cellular like yeah that we do it
we don't even lower it we just drop it
drop it and it sounds like a mistake it
sounds like someone is sounding he's
getting fired yes and it's because it's
like
we care so much for the living yeah you
know in that way that it's like
th this person is gone and now we have
to take care of the people that are here
because they're gonna die too and then
they're leaving people and a lot of
times we do this on the run we do it
that way i think sp specifically because
it's such a part of our
you had to get good and grieving because
there was a lot of it yeah and so the it
was like we mastered
the idea of the loss of life and the
people again like the people that are
left to like be there to clean up that's
why like
you know
in a jewish community a parent dies it's
like
there's a rush to take care of those
kids and it's not
for like altruistic you know what i mean
it's like they that's what you do that's
what's our pack it's that's the pack you
have to do that and i feel like i'm i'm
i really love that i'm lucky to to have
that and to be to
to be raised
so jewy
um even though i don't believe in the
religion but that's not
no of course you know what i mean that's
like getting in the weeds it's like
christian people like
you know it's like do you believe that
like
we're eating christ at church you know
what i mean it's rituals it's all that
stuff and so we need we need that
comforting but i think that the one of
the things that judaism really does is
that they're insanely i mean again not
to bring it back to the abortion
um debate but and again that's the two
might remember like
abortion is
essential in judaism
we
we have no like that bible rule is from
goys
that like
we don't say that yeah
we care about the woman and the mother
and
like so the fact that now i have to
do that for my daughter
i'm not christian yeah
that's my religion there's no part of
that but why it's so it's like
there's a certain aspect of judaism
that's like has a lot of humanity in it
that is being
challenged in this like new
christian right
i think by crazy people for sure i'm
gonna finish this loop that i brought up
so long ago
um
i remember a lot of my jewish friends
being very uh
sad when jennifer gray got the nose job
yes
and i i i fall in that skill like that
was like
do what you want to do no it's not you
know your body your choice that also
applies to your face yeah i don't mean
and again like i i'm a man and i know
that and i don't want to say like it
bothered me
i think a lot of people i know were like
that was the first she because she
looked like me i mean i was in love with
jennifer gray you know because it was
like she was a jewish
you know she was like the hottest jewish
girl who could dance
you know i was like and
you know even as ferris bueller's sister
my god like that was what
she kicks him and that leg goes so high
and she's wearing those ankle warmers
it's like sexy shit you know and like
especially the young age and then now
it's like she should look the way she
wants to look
uh it's crazy that she like never really
worked again well it's hard to change i
mean yeah
yeah
i mean i think it's cool not to shout
out one of my friends like i think it's
cool that ben schwartz is famous yeah oh
when we were coming up when we were 19
and in a sketch group together
my dad was like he's gonna have to
change his name
and i was like and he's not just playing
like lawyers no he's a leading man
exactly and like i think it's fucking
awesome that ben schwartz is famous like
great it's we don't have many like that
yeah you know and certainly if we do
their names are not schwartz yeah so i
think it's cool it is gosh it's it's so
like there's so much to unpack
yeah and i wrote i wrote about this a
couple months ago when people were like
um getting on jon stewart when there was
this whole there was this backlash about
jon stewart
use changing his name
because he has like a more jewish name
and there was like an uproar about it
that this this guy who's like a beacon
of honesty
is like lying about his name and i was
like okay people love to find out a jew
has a fake they love it there's nothing
that excites the masses more than
finding out someone's name is not stuart
you know they get like
you see this guy is sneaking around
where it's like was it jewish people
mostly or no like no not jewish people
because all jews know why he changed his
name yeah well you wouldn't have watched
otherwise in the beginning yet and it's
like they love it it's a huge uproar
reese witherspoon is not her real name
jamie foxx is not his real name
it's jamie stein it's jamie schwartz
and reese tom cruise but like no yeah
it's like
that has been going on for years and
years yeah of course
why are people upset at jon stewart
it
because he's a jew and and you felt it's
like
panic you know
i don't get it and and still it's people
talk about jonah they're like you know
hill's not his last name
and it's like got you you know what got
him you got him got him you honestly if
that's what you got him on must be
having a pretty good yeah make pretty
good choices you got him you're right
yeah half the people in this business
are rapists who gives a shit yeah like
how is this speaking of priority no this
is totally on another thing but i do
have to say it
gil you know gil galiozari from he's so
funny he's now
writing on on every uh nick crowe show
and for sash he's amazing but he he um
uh him and i were we had an old script
and a producer got it recently and was
like i want to take a meeting
so we took the meeting and we were like
he's like yeah i just um
the the main character there's so many
actors we could go to you know it's like
an older guy we go to de niro we go to
mel gibson
and i was like what he's got 13 movies
in production
13 1-3 it's
yeah mind like that is where you're
really like nimbling
but here's what's happening like
hollywood gives a pass to alcoholics
they love a drunk downy junior with stan
but like
you know he's iron man like that if it
was like he was drunk we lo we love a
man that drunkenly made a big mistake
and we just wanna that's so he has made
so many but if you have a drinking
problem everyone's fine everyone's like
he's just gotta sober up and then he
won't be anti-semitic anymore like
really yeah i think he also needs to
you're losing those tapes he needs to
catch his breath oh i he's like
consistently winning
you're getting that chicken
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude get the guy some oxygen exactly he
was so bummed about his leg he's like
sold his legs
like bitch they haven't won in 30 years
yeah the jew tape is great too because
he's like wanna know why all the wars
are in the world and the guy's like you
were driving 75-35
he's like i'll tell you why
the jews control the weather
we'll let him go you want to be in
daddy's home too
no problem no problem
oh nine picture deals mgm yeah people
listen to those tapes and we're like i
thought i forgot how funny mel actually
is
he should do
hilarious
more
love bird on a wire you know he should
play like a villain yeah you know be
great if like ooh tropic thunder two and
it's a mel in the tom cruise role and
he's a jew did you hear that monologue
he did to that russian girl
it's hilarious mel's like i have some
questions about the uh
the sides
i bet he's bummed that mel is the most
jewish name
it's just sort of like i mean it feels a
little bit like
his dad's like a full-on nazi too it's
like
bummer like the fact that his dad was
like and we will name him
mel
another one secures this is the
strongest aryan yet his name shall be
mel
[Laughter]
the superior race does that stand for
something the superior race is all small
syllabic names we are all mel but also
wait hey mel gibson remember
remember when you got famous like
putting on pantyhose yes like that you
were just like i'm a girl and we were
like
mel gibson has always been problematic
i'm shocked
that that dude like well that that was
like it was just like you know be funny
what if i were he what if i you know it
was i mean someone else wrote that movie
so braveheart is like
problematic human is a problematic movie
it's like
there are when he overtook the savages
like what did they say we will get these
savages
it's basically like early colonization i
mean it's like they're it's the story of
like people
you may take our land it's like wha what
excuse me
you will never take
our freedom
it's like
that's actually what they said when they
were in charleston but it's also yeah
it's hilarious because you're white you
have a lot plenty of freedom like you're
not i don't think you have a freedom
issue dude who was ever stopping mel
gives him for doing i'm not trying to
take your freedom i just think that face
paint looks ridiculous
blue man group the one true story that
must be told is of william wallace
who's that ah
a fringe character from
irish history
famous for
colonizing ireland
killing all the indigenous people
then being put on a rack and it'll have
three sex scenes
with three different women
first his wife will kill her
then the second wife she'll die of a
sickness
then the third wife who reminds him of
the two
[Laughter]
my favorite thing is like you know he's
such a like like um
like curmudgeonly like prickly person
imagine the makeup artist that had to
apply the blue to him oh yeah constantly
he's just like snapping it's fucking
cunt like you know or doing he's like
take our
take our
take on our work you need to fix you
touch your face and there's just blue
you move the you i need a caroline
i said permanent
it's just spreading everywhere i wanted
it to be blackfish i said old
black what is this half blue
i said braveheart would be all black oh
blue this isn't funny at all
what am i fighting for the israeli army
we'll talk about this later what if i
pro ukraine we'll talk about this in my
jacuzzi
but not at all
and i won't be at the lakers game thank
you very much
[Laughter]
hello
billy he goes he's like harvey
call me in 10 minutes so i can get out
of this billy crystal conversation i
don't want to talk to this asshole
thanks kevin's barbie's not answering
call bob
one of the brothers
had something to do with it
surely one new it is amazing that the
one brother is just like chilling oh
yeah he's like got a place in the
hamptons just like chilling bob was like
i never liked the name miramax
[Laughter]
cops are like so you never heard
anything through the office door he's
like
mostly
mostly arguments about budget
the scream franchise
okay i want to ask any further questions
no further questions mr weinstein
[Music]
like where is the brother
meanwhile when the when the one when
harvey was like so high it was like five
picture deal for bob weinstein who's
that he's my less smart brother
who just works all he works all day he
doesn't even own a bathrobe
he doesn't dig
doesn't know how to get an actress to
agree yeah julian project
he runs our horror
arm he tries to cast ugly women
that are over 20. he got charlize her
oscar
i hate you so much
i don't know what to do i
thank you for having me and letting me
come on it's it's so nice to to for you
guys that let me be here and promote the
show so i really appreciate it again i
will do it again none of the talk shows
matter that's for sure
emailed you
please have me out i'm excited because
you have to understand all the people
that i really want to have the podcast
are the kind of people i would never ask
to be on the podcast because i get
embarrassed you can always ask me i just
am like i'm like ugh i don't want to be
that person one time i was sarah
silverman does like a yearly like
rooftop like party yeah we've been there
we've been there yeah and there's a sign
that says no soliciting for podcasts
when you walk in it's just like so funny
it's great because it is it is this
thing now when you're at the comic store
party and someone walks up to you you're
like so i really want to say hi to you
but if you announce me to your podcast
you know so it's like people i like well
i mean i i have no
like i need to promote and like i'm this
means more than a talk show and it's so
it's exciting to get
people like people that i love who i
love their personality people get to
like
i got to come on and do like two hours
of piss
heaven on earth yeah we we both
got like two holding deals and then lost
them soon oh yeah no no based on what we
post on instagram a lot of good things
and then they'll list the whole episode
be like uh oh yeah no it's no we'll cut
well this will be 20 minutes okay good
that's about my ratio
of bullshit to solid usable stuff
that's about what my happy endings ratio
was i end these very awkwardly as you
know adam pali 101 places to party
before you die it is on true tv but as
you know
don't
don't worry just google it yeah you'll
find it you don't need to know the
streamer i can tell you where you'll see
it definitely if you've been in an
accident or in a hospital waiting room
true tv is always playing
that's pretty much the only place so why
am i still doing casey kasem i don't
know i'm telling you right now all you
got to do is get on true tv where it
plays for people who wake up out of
comas and
that's my core audience
they're like i have brain damage i
thought true was about t-r-u-e and
they're like nope where are the
impractical jokers
we're sal
cue
am i on the yacht
fat
bearded people
they look like they're having fun okay
i'm obsessed with you um 101 places to
party before you die if you don't watch
this you simply hate yourself adam pally
um also take another glance at
filthy grandpa it doesn't matter
it truly doesn't matter just his body of
work it just really speaks for itself
not my body but my body of work my
body's more like
baldwin right now than
i'd like it to be
and not
this is this entire episode is basically
the main thread it's all the ball but
yeah i don't mind no
i mean we both worked with him dodged a
bullet and
don't write elephants lucky to make it
out alive
[Music]